voy a empezar con una pregunta y si la
Guerra de Ucrania estuviera provocando
una hambruna gigantesca en África
[Música]
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero vamos a ver si Rusia y Ucrania
están aquí y África está aquí pues sí es
verdad pero es que la guerra ha puesto
patas arriba al mundo entero ya os hemos
contado en un montón de vídeos aquí en
visualpolitik Cómo ha llegado a
convertir los mercados energéticos en un
enorme caos sin embargo esta no está
siendo la única consecuencia de este
conflicto la gran Ucrania también está
poniendo contra las cuerdas otro
importantísimo mercado el mercado
agrícola pensadlo bien es muy difícil
vivir sin petróleo o sin gas natural y
con los precios de estos hidrocarburos
disparados vamos a pasarlo mal sin
embargo vivir sin trigo sin maíz resulta
mucho más complicado de hecho para
millones y millones de personas la falta
de estos alimentos puede suponer la
diferencia entre comer o morirse de
hambre y diréis vale pero que tiene que
ver Rusia Ucrania en todo esto pues
mucho más de lo que os podríais imaginar
básicamente porque estamos hablando de
dos de los mayores productores agrícolas
de todo el planeta seguro que
prácticamente todos por no decir todos
los que veáis este vídeo da igual que
viváis en Europa Estados Unidos o
incluso en América Latina habréis notado
Que los precios de la comida han subido
y mucho durante el último año pues ya
sabéis cuál está siendo uno de los
grandes motivos la Guerra de Ucrania sin
duda está siendo duro y muy duro para
muchos de vosotros pero por fortuna en
general en esta parte del mundo no nos
estamos muriendo de hambre sin embargo
hay un lugar del planeta en el que no se
puede decir lo mismo el África
subsahariana
ya os hemos contado muchas veces aquí en
visualpolitik como en el mundo y
particularmente en este área tan
deprimida se han conseguido tantos
avances en los últimos años que para
muchos las hambrunas estaban condenadas
a no ser más que malos capítulos en los
libros de historia de hecho hasta hace
unos pocos años parecía que el hambre o
sea el hambre extrema las hambrunas era
algo que ya había prácticamente
desaparecido y en este caso los sectores
agrícolas de Rusia y Ucrania habían sido
claves para que os hagáis una idea
Ucrania producía cada año alimentos para
400 millones de personas muchas de ellas
del África subsahariana pero la guerra
lo ha complicado todo las exportaciones
de grano desde Ucrania y desde Rusia ya
no son ni tan cuantiosas ni tan
frecuentes como lo eran antes de que
Vladimir Putin lanzara sus tropas sobre
su país vecino Y por supuesto esto ha
hecho que la tensión en los mercados
agrícolas se dispare y ojo no solo
porque los puertos ucranianos del mar
Negro estén en constante punto de mira
de Rusia o porque los combates hayan
limitado la producción de Ucrania sino
es que incluso las sanciones a Rusia
hacen que ahora las exportaciones sean
mucho más difíciles y mucho más caras el
resultado la posibilidad de que se
produzca una crisis alimentaria salvaje
No había sido tan alta desde los años 80
Así que la pregunta que nos hacemos es
qué iniciativas están impulsando para
evitar una hambruna catastrófica Por qué
vendían Rusia y Ucrania tantísimo trigo
África y otras dos preguntas que pueden
sorprenderte aún más Qué pinta
turquiento de esta historia puede
Turquía conseguir evitar una hambruna en
todo el mundo hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
tecnología producción y trabajo duro
si sois veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik recordaréis que una de las
cosas que hemos repetido hasta la
saciedad en este canal Es que el número
de personas que sufren la pobreza
extrema y que pasan hambre ha estado
cayendo en picado en todo el mundo
durante las últimas décadas en lo que
llevamos de Siglo XXI el hambre extrema
ha dejado de ser algo habitual en el
mundo a concentrarse en alguna región
muy concreta del planeta y esto se debe
sobre todo a una razón los avances
tecnológicos y ojo Porque si os
preguntará qué sector económico se ha
desarrollado más en las últimas décadas
Seguro seguro que la mayoría pensaríais
en la industria la informática o cosas
por el estilo me equivoco seguro que no
y en cierto modo tenéis razón pero
sabéis que la evolución del sector
agrícola ha sido mucho más impresionante
que la de cualquier otra industria para
que os hagáis una idea a principios del
siglo XX en Europa o en Estados Unidos
todavía nos podíamos encontrar con
imágenes como esta sin embargo hoy en
día en los campos de los países más
desarrollados nos podemos encontrar
cosas como esta Exacto cada vez es más
frecuente Ver cosas como tractores sin
conductores robots de regadío drones y
muchísimos otros avances tecnológicos
que Reproducir cada año muchos más
alimentos con menos esfuerzo y todo eso
por no hablar de los alimentos
genéticamente modificados Lo cierto es
que en las próximas décadas puede que
veamos un enorme crecimiento de la
producción alimentaria un salto que ya
hemos experimentado hace unas pocas
décadas porque entre los años 60 y 80 se
produjo todo un vuelco de 180 grados en
los mercados agrícolas por supuesto os
estoy hablando de la conocida como
Revolución verde
[Música]
la revolución verde no hace otra cosa
que un gigantesco aumento de la
productividad de la agricultura a nivel
global empezó en México y en Estados
Unidos a finales de los 50 con la
revolución del trigo y poco a poco se
fue extendiendo por todo el mundo el
aumento de la productividad se produjo
gracias al uso de nuevas tecnologías la
siembra de cereales resistentes a los
climas y las plagas más extremas y el
uso de fertilizantes sintéticos y
plaguicidas de esta forma los países de
América Latina y de toda Asia como
México Pakistán o la India lograron
su producción
[Música]
Pero por supuesto el caso más conocido
fue el de China un país donde la
revolución verde junto a las reformas
Pro mercado puestas en marcha por densia
o pin logró reducir los niveles de
hambruna a mínimos históricos podríamos
decir que la revolución verde dejó
temblando hasta el más fiel maltusiano
es decir seguidor del geógrafo John
malthus ya que probó claramente que el
aumento de la producción es totalmente
compatible con el aumento de la
población y que el hambre en el mundo se
podía erradicar y no solo eso también
confirmó otra tendencia que hoy ya es
más que evidente que una mayor
producción no significa más gente
trabajando en la agricultura de hecho
ahora vivimos en una interesantísima
paradoja porque al mismo tiempo que hay
menos gente trabajando en el campo cada
vez la producción agrícola es mayor sin
embargo esperad un momento porque no
todo el mundo ha disfrutado de los
efectos de esta Revolución verde no hay
una región que se resiste al avance
tecnológico hablamos del África
subsahariana la única Región del mundo
que no se pudo unir con éxito a esta
llamada Revolución verde y diréis por
qué
Pues por varias razones la primera y
quizás la más importante es que mientras
el resto de países estaban ya
independizados durante la Revolución
verde muchos de los países del África
subsahariana estaban aún luchando por
liberarse de sus colonizadores y cuando
lo consiguieron las luchas internas por
el poder y los gobiernos corruptos
comenzaron a florecer haciendo
prácticamente imposible el desarrollo de
proyectos de infraestructura que
permitieran incrementar la producción y
luego transportarla de un lado a otro
por supuesto la inversión y el
desarrollo de la agricultura necesitan
suficientes infraestructuras como para
poder exportar rápidamente a su
producción pero no solo eso Por ejemplo
esta también es una de las razones por
las que el uso de fertilizantes es tan
reducido en esta región porque los
costes de transportes son mucho más
elevados y si a todo esto lo unimos que
las condiciones climáticas son extremas
en muchas zonas del África subsahariana
Entonces tenemos el cóctel perfecto para
explicar el subdesarrollo que vive este
sector en la región esto es precisamente
lo que explica en buena medida porque
aquí la agricultura de subsistencia
Sigue estando a la orden del día y por
qué tantos países de la región tienen
que importar los alimentos y como encima
la población No para de crecer Pues el
problema está servido la demanda para
importar alimentos es cada vez mayor y
como os podéis imaginar con semejante
panorama la Guerra de Ucrania ha sido
como un misil estallando en la mismísima
línea de flotación porque sí mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik este es
exactamente el principal motivo por el
que la Guerra de Ucrania se ha
convertido en todo una enorme pesadilla
para el continente olvidado atentos
[Música]
Innovación financiera contra las
hambrunas
os acordáis de los activistas
anticlavalización a principios del siglo
XXI teníamos a muchísimas personas
diciendo cosas como que la globalización
financiera iba a destruir por completo
el tercer mundo y que las diferencias
entre los países ricos y los países
pobres aumentarían de manera
catastrófica pues bien la realidad no
podía estar más lejos de esta narrativa
en este vídeo ya os hemos contado como
la evolución tecnológica ha multiplicado
la producción agrícola hasta el punto de
reducir drásticamente las hambrunas en
todo el mundo pero lo que todavía nos
hemos contado es como las innovaciones
financieras también han ayudado a acabar
con el hambre en el mundo habéis oído
bien innovaciones financieras hablamos
concretamente del conocido como el
mercado de futuros agrícola y os
preguntaréis Pero qué son estos mercados
Pues básicamente son mercados donde se
pueden comprar y vender muy fácilmente
los productos agrícolas como el trigo o
el maíz sin tener que estar moviéndolos
todo el rato son instrumentos
financieros que permiten garantizarte el
suministro de alimentos en el futuro por
eso se llaman futuros en realidad estos
mercados de futuros no son algo nuevo ni
muchísimo menos es más llevan entre
nosotros muchísimo más de lo que os
podáis imaginar
el primer mercado de futuros agrícolas
se registró en Estados Unidos en
1848 fue el Chicago born off Trade pero
no fue hasta los años 60 y 70 cuando
podemos hablar de un verdadero mercado
global y totalmente abierto en el que
comprar y Vender productos agrícolas
como las producciones podían venderse De
antemano crecieron las inversiones En el
sector y con ellas las exportaciones
agrícolas se dispararon
y así es como nació un nuevo mercado
global Gracias a él los países en vías
de desarrollo que tienen más dificultad
para producir sus propios alimentos
pudieron acceder a un montón de nuevos
alimentos mucho más baratos en otras
palabras que los países del África
subsahariana que no pudieron engancharse
a la revolución verde pudieron suplir
esta escasez productiva con las compras
en el mercado internacional y esto
contribuyó como os podéis imaginar a
reducir estas hambrunas ojo esto no
significa que el hambre en el mundo haya
desaparecido ni muchísimo menos sin ir
más lejos ahí tenemos la dramática
hambruna por la que está pasando somalia
como resultado de una dura sequía y que
ha acabado ya con más de 43.000 Vidas
por otro lado el hecho de que estos
países dependan tantísimo de las
importaciones del trigo y otros cereales
los hacen más vulnerables a las propias
fluctuaciones del mercado internacional
lo vimos ya durante la gran crisis
financiera del año 2008 que provocó
también una enorme crisis alimentaria y
lo volvimos a ver en 2020 con la
pandemia del cobi 19 y el colapso de las
cadenas de suministro pero es que ahora
la situación es mucho más dramática Y
diréis por qué pues échale un vistazo
Cuáles son los principales exportadores
de grano del mundo
Exacto mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik Rusia es el principal
exportador de grano de todo el planeta
tierra y Ucrania es el quinto mayor y ni
siquiera hablamos solo de granos también
son enormes exportadores de otros muchos
productos Ahí está por ejemplo el caso
del aceite de girasol del que Ucrania
tenía una cuota de Mercado a nivel
mundial del 46%. pensad que sus tierras
negras es decir el chernócem son muy
ricas en nutrientes y junto a las
reformas desde la caída de la unión
soviética han hecho que estos dos países
aumenten su producción agrícola hasta el
punto de convertirse en los graneros de
buena parte de Europa y buena parte del
mundo sin ir más lejos países como benín
tanzania o el Congo importan más del 70%
de su grano desde Rusia precisamente por
eso la Guerra sin cuartel que ahora
enfrenta a Rusia con Ucrania ha hecho
soltar todas las alarmas los precios se
han disparado y la inseguridad
alimentaria se ha vuelto a convertir en
un tema de moda la pregunta Entonces es
que se está haciendo para evitar otra
catástrofe humanitaria en el África
subsahariana Cómo se está intentando
domar los precios Pues bien ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y Turquía que pinta aquí
ya os hemos contado que Ucrania era y
sigue siendo uno de los mayores
productores de grano del mundo sin ir
más lejos el 72% de toda su población
rural trabaja en la agricultura pero la
guerra ha resultado devastadora para
este mercado entre los bombardeos el
reclutamiento forzoso y El dominio naval
de Rusia en el mar Negro los costes de
producción para Ucrania han aumentado de
forma Nacho vidaliana además se estima
que el 25% de todos los hogares
ucranianos que vivían del agro han
suspendido sus actividades ahora bien No
solo Ucrania tiene problemas Rusia
tampoco se Libra es cierto los países
occidentales no impusieron sanciones
contra su sector agrícola y en principio
deberían tenerlo mucho más fácil para
exportar al resto del mundo dado que
dominan el mar Negro sin embargo las
sanciones económicas están afectándoles
indirectamente por qué Pues porque al
estar excluidos de los sistemas de pagos
internacionales tener su logística
sancionada y negarse las aseguradoras a
trabajar con los cargamentos rusos su
sector agrícolas está resintiendo tanto
como el ucraniano seguro que ahora
podéis entender un gráfico como este
pues sí Esto es lo que explica que
cuando bajéis a la panadería la barra de
pan en lugar de costar 70 céntimos de
euro pase a valer prácticamente un euro
obviamente no solo se trata de pan sino
también de la mayor parte de la cesta de
alimentos y claro lo que en Europa o en
Estados Unidos significa que a lo mejor
no podamos llegar a fin de mes o que
tengamos ciertas incomodidades en
regiones como el África subsahariana
puede suponer la diferencia entre comer
o pasar hambre o incluso morirse de
hambre y por eso la comodidad
internacional empezó a reclamar cambios
para evitar lo que podría ser una
catástrofe alimentaria y sabéis que aquí
es cuando entra en escena Turquía y
diréis Qué pinta Turquía en esto
[Música]
el papel de Turquía en la guerra
desatada por Rusia ha sido cuanto menos
ambivalente no ha sancionado a Rusia
pero tampoco le ha prestado su apoyo ya
que es miembro de la otan e incluso el
país a suministrado armas al ejército
ucraniano pero más allá de eso lo cierto
Es que en términos generales ha buscado
jugar un papel de cierta neutralidad
Turquía ha aprovechado este conflicto
para mover ficha en el tablero
internacional e intentar granjearse una
mayor simpatía internacional al
presentarse como el mediador entre ambos
países y claro estando en el mar Negro y
teniendo el control del estrecho del
bósforo Turquía ha jugado un papel clave
a la hora de intentar restablecer las
exportaciones de grano desde el mar
Negro de hecho junto con las Naciones
Unidas ha sido el precursor de una
iniciativa crucial para reducir los
precios del grano mundiales la
iniciativa de granos del mar Negro
y diréis en qué consiste esta iniciativa
pues muy simple Rusia Se compromete a no
bombardear los barcos ucranianos que
lleven grano desde el mar Negro de esta
forma Ucrania puede habilitar tres
puertos para llevar a cabo sus
exportaciones el diodesa el de
chernomorsk y el de yuxne y Turquía a
cambio revisa todas las embarcaciones en
los cargamentos en Estambul cuando
entran y salen los barcos ucranianos Por
qué pues para evitar que por ejemplo
puedan transportar armas en principio es
una bien verdad pues hay que reconocer
que en este caso la iniciativa ha tenido
bastante éxito
[Música]
como podéis ver los precios tanto del
trigo como del Maíz han estado cayendo
desde el mismo momento en el que se
firmó esta iniciativa sin embargo
también hemos visto momentos Donde ha
habido mucha incertidumbre Por qué Pues
porque Rusia parece que quería romper el
acuerdo lo que ha hecho que cada dos por
tres repunte otra vez los precios y es
que Moscú ha estado jugando con esta
iniciativa porque intentan utilizarla
para que algunas sanciones se suavicen
eso explica que cuando firmaron el
acuerdo en julio de 2022 lo hicieran
solamente por cuatro meses y en
noviembre cuando fueron a renovarlo
también pero justo el 18 de marzo cuando
tenía que volverlo a renovar lo hicieron
solo por 60 días y diréis por qué Pues
porque quieren apretarle las tuercas a
los países occidentales y no solo eso
Rusia quiere explotar intensamente su
posición fijaos si finalmente decidimos
no prorrogar el acuerdo dentro de 60
días estamos dispuestos a suministrar
desde Rusia gratuitamente a estos países
todo el volumen enviado durante el
último tiempo a los países africanos que
lo necesiten especialmente Vladimir
Putin francamente no podremos estar
seguros de que esto vaya a ser así hasta
que Rusia decida retirarse de la
iniciativa si es que termina haciéndolo
Pero eso de dar algo gratis no parece
bastante realista
[Música]
por ejemplo ya os hemos contado la
estrategia de Rusia en África y como el
grupo de mercenarios rusos Wagner muy
vinculado al kremlin no presta sus
servicios de manera altruista el oro
siempre va por delante pero incluso
Aunque estuvieran dispuesto a hacerlo es
decir aunque estuvieran dispuestos a dar
grano de forma totalmente gratuita es
muy difícil por no decir imposible que
lograran reemplazar la producción
ucraniana y por eso esta iniciativa es
crucial para todas las partes no solo
para que los precios bajen los mercados
internacionales sino también para evitar
lo que sería una nueva catástrofe
alimentaria en la región más vulnerable
del planeta el África subsahariana
pensando así en este caso el problema de
Rusia jugando con los plazos de
ampliación de su participación en este
acuerdo no solo genera una gran
incertidumbre en los mercados sino
también en el día a día de cientos de
millones de personas de momento Estas
son las expectativas para el año 2023 en
un mercado que ya de por sí está muy
pero que muy presionado La cosecha
mundial de cereal caerá un 2,2% en la
campaña 2022 23 según Estados Unidos y
llegados hasta aquí turno para vosotros
creéis que Rusia romperá finalmente su
participación en la iniciativa del grano
del mar Negro volveremos a presenciar
otra crisis alimentaria de grandes
dimensiones que soluciones creéis que
podrían ser viables para aliviar la
situación podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]